welcome back I'm now going to use
definite integrals to to figure out the
areas under a bunch of curves and if we
have time maybe even between some curves
so let me write down the fundamental
theorem of calculus i I know I covered
it really fast in the last presentation
just to make sure you understand this
formula the last couple presentations
will really give you an intuition for
this exact formula let's say that big
big f prime of x is equal to f of X
right that's also sit like saying that
the that's equivalent to saying that f
of X big f of X is equal to the
antiderivative of f of X right and the
reason why the reason why well let's
just say it's equal it's one of the
possible antiderivative of f of X right
because there's always a constant term
here and you're not sure whether it is
and this is why that people tend to use
this standard because we know that f of
X is the derivative of big f prime of X
big f of X is just one of the
antiderivative of f of X so this is a
little bit a little bit not true but I
think you get the idea
but the fundamental theorem of calculus
tells us if this top line is true then
the definite integral from A to B of f
of X DX is equal to its antiderivative
evaluated at B minus its antiderivative
evaluated it a and I know I said here
that F big F isn't the only
antiderivative right because you could
add any constant to this and that would
also be the antiderivative but when you
subtract here the constants will cancel
out so it really doesn't matter which of
the constants you pick the constant
actually doesn't matter so that's why I
actually said the antiderivative
but let's apply this is you might be
confused right now so let's say let me
draw some
let me draw a graph there you go look
look how straight that is draw the
x-axis not perfect but it'll do it'll do
and let's say I have D let's say that my
f of X f of X is equal to x squared plus
1 so f of X looks like this this is one
this one so it'll start at one it'll
just be a parabola so look see how good
I can draw this I've done worse okay so
that's f of X its parabola y-intercept
at 1 and let's say I want to figure out
the area under the curve between the
curve and really the x-axis let's say I
want to figure out the area between the
curve and the x-axis from x equals
negative 1/2 I don't know x equals 3 so
this is the area I want to figure out
I'm going to shade it in whoops so it's
this this is the area all of this stuff
I want to figure out this area and you
could imagine before you knew calculus
figuring out an area of something with a
curve as it's kind of top boundary would
have been very difficult but we will now
use a fundamental theorem of calculus
and hopefully you have an intuition of
why this works and and how the the
integral is really just a sum of a bunch
of little little small squares with with
infinitely small bases but if you watch
the last videos hopefully that that hit
the point home but well now we'll just
mechanically compute because actually
understanding it is a bit harder than
just doing it but let's just
mechanically compute it so we are
essentially just going to figure out the
integral from minus 1 to 3 of f of X
which is x squared plus 1
DX well let's what's the antiderivative
of x squared plus one well this just
equals the antiderivative so it's just X
to the third we could say one-third X to
the third R X to the third over 3 plus X
right the derivative of X is 1 and then
we don't have to worry about plus C
because we're going to subtract out the
C's you'll see I think you'll get the
point it doesn't matter you could pick
an arbitrary C right here and we'll just
cancel out and we're going to evaluate
that at 3 and negative 1 and we're going
to subtract out big F of negative 1 from
big F of 3 this is just the notation
they use you figure out the
antiderivative and you say where you're
going to evaluate it and then this is
equal to so if I evaluate 3 3 to the
third power is 1 that's 27 27 divided by
3 is not a is 9 and then 9 plus 3 is 12
right this is just big F of 3 right
because I figured out the AMPA this is
this is big F this is big f of X you can
kind of view this as big f of X but not
to be confused with small cursive f of X
this is big f of X so this big F of 3
and then from that will subtract big F
of negative 1 all right - big F of
negative 1 and if we put minus 1 here
let's see minus 1 to the third power is
minus 1 so it's minus 1/3 and then plus
minus 1 right so minus 1/3 plus minus 1
I think that's minus that equals minus
4/3 correct I think so maybe I'm making
a mistake with negative signs minus 1/3
minus 1 is minus 4/3 now I'm gonna
subtract that right so if I'm
subtracting minus 4/3 that's the same
thing as adding minus 4/3 and then we
have our answer to what well we actually
don't even have to add wheat it's 12 and
4/3 whatever units square units 12 and 4
thirds squared units we could write this
as a mixed number as well let's do it
let's do another one I'll do a slight
slight variation
image invert okay so let's let me draw
again some coordinates I don't know if
I'm enough time to do it in this video
but I'll try I always try and let's say
I have f of X so I'm still using the
line tool
let's have f of X is equal to the square
root of x right so it looks something
like this if I X is equal it looks
something like this right something like
that that's actually pretty nice-looking
a kind of sideways parabola I think and
this is f of X and let's say I have
another function G of X which equals x
squared so G of X is actually going to
look something like this
whoops I was doing well and then
something happened and of course it'll
continue on this side as well all right
because it is defined for negative
numbers but anyway my question to you or
my question to myself really is what is
the area between the curves where they
intersect right here so like what is
this what is this area well the first
thing you have to figure out is just
what are the boundary points what is
this point and what is this point
well this point I think it's pretty
clear it's it's zero zero right they
both they both intersect zero zero and
even this point you could probably do it
from from intuition but if you don't if
you don't I guess I want to do it
through intuition you could just set the
two equations equal to each other right
you could say x squared is equal to the
square root of x right and then you
could say well you can do a bunch of
things you could you could square both
sides or well yeah actually this is the
same thing as doing it by intuition but
I think it's pretty obvious that the
only places where x squared is equal to
the square root of x is are the points x
equals zero which you already know and x
equals one so this is the point 1 comma
1 which is true for both of them it is
more algebra so I won't go into that too
much detail I know I'm kind of running
out of time so we want to figure out the
area between these two curves so what we
can do is maybe you want to pause it and
think about it yourself we can figure
out the area under this under the gray
curve we could figure out this area so
we want to figure out this is the
boundary right between 0 and 1 we could
figure out this area and then we could
figure out the entire area under the
green curve separately and then we could
subtract the difference which is exactly
how we're going to do it in the next
video because I have run out of time